one of the lessons from your book The
Hollywood game plan is that any creative
needs to understand that this is a
dollar-driven industry can you explain
sure it's one thing to create and that's
fabulous you're an artist we need you to
do that but this is a business and the
best most successful
screenwriters and directors and
producers and even actors they know that
they have to create and sell they have
to sell themselves uh producers have to
sell their product it is not just I mean
if you want to just be an artist take up
uh watercolors but if you want to be in
this business and succeed you have to
tell and
sell tell and sell what does that entail
well if we're talking about let's say
say pitching um then you have to tell
the story of the show you want to make
and you have to sell it you you you have
to say it in a way that gets people
excited about it and um leaning forward
and can't wait to hear more um and your
job is to sell a lot of creatives feel
like if I just have a manager or an
agent they'll do all the work that is
not not true everybody wants to believe
that but it's not true you have to work
as hard as you did before even when you
have an
representation is it true that nothing
is green lit unless it's viewed as
profitable that is really an interesting
question I I think the right answer to
that or an obvious answer to that is who
is green lighting if it's a nonprofit
organization they don't care if it's a
for-profit organization a studio a
network a production company although
mostly production companies can't green
light mostly Studios and and uh
Executives and networks or cable
channels or streaming they're in this to
make money uh they may love your project
some people some decision makers go I
just love that project and they may they
may order something they know won't be
as profitable but they love it so much
they're going to make it that doesn't
happen all that often do you get a lot
of push back from the people that you
mentor on this topic push back in terms
of why do I have to sell or why are they
only picking up things that will make
money both um I think people artists you
know what I mean creatives um would
rather not sell they would rather think
that the business is about putting out
art and but most of my clients most of
the people I Mentor they're Savvy enough
to realize that this is a business
there's show and then there's business
Show Business and they may be unhappy
but they don't really push back because
they understand that people are in it to
make a profit now you don't want to just
make something that you think will make
money to pitch something or sell
something just to make money you want
your heart to be in it and you want to
be passionate about it
but uh yeah it has to be something
that's going to make money well if we
want our heart to be in it I mean so
many of our own stories we
think that's what what we would be sort
of dialed into but not everybody is
going to find us interesting and so we
have to know that there may not be an
audience for a very Niche
story I think no matter how Niche your
story is if you can find the universal
themes in it
um that makes it much more salable I
have a client who's a director and she's
writing a feature and she's writing a
feature based on her own experience of
being a mom and a mom who's a director
but took time off to have her child and
isn't sure how she's going to get back
in so she wrote something about female a
female fine artist who sacrificed her
artistic Ambitions to take care of her
husband and family and I said that's
okay that's only going to be interesting
to women you've got to make it something
that all of us who've ever stood up for
for ourselves in spite of the obstacles
can relate to so no matter how specific
your story is if you make it Universal
Universal themes you're going to have a
much easier time of selling it so almost
genderless in some sense genderless
because then we we were eliminating
maybe half the audience right although
specific I you know it's interesting
about gender list I wouldn't say gender
list I would say gender specific if
that's what you want to write but that
what the story you're telling is
something that all genders can relate to
because such a human story sure I mean
there's fathers equally maybe even more
so that have sacrificed sort of a dream
or a calling yeah in in the name of
making money yeah what do you think
about projects that are made with
passion first profits last right for for
the artist for the writer for the
producer I think that's a way you lead
you lead with your passion it's not up
to you necessarily to think about
whether this will make a profit although
if you're smart you'll put your business
hat on as well as your artist hat on
from a buyer's
perspective passion projects
always have the possibility
of being so deep and so compelling that
they will feel like there's profit
availability there
but they put profit first they're happy
that you're passionate about it sometime
that really moves them uh and there's
development Executives and creative
Executives at Studios who your passion
maybe the thing that gets them excited
to kick it upstairs but the final
decision
makers they are going to look at the
bottom
line and so is that like the real litmus
test is is I can be a creative and think
that my personal story is it's just
going to change the world but I'm
blinded by my own experience and so is
that where getting feedback from a
script consultant some type of a a
writing group before taking it and
trying to pitch it is so help
absolutely did I step on you there no no
okay um
absolutely before anybody takes anything
out to pitch to try and sell to get
representation you should have many eyes
on it you should have people who are
regular people uh not in the business
get their feedback but then take it to
somebody in the business who understands
how the business Works to read it
and say you know what it's not there yet
or this is fabulous it's a home run
don't take anything out before it's been
vetted because you only get one shot you
really only get one shot and you don't
want to blow that by having it not
formatted correctly or being so insular
that nobody else is going to be
interested in it when you say one shot
do you mean one shot for that particular
project or just one shot in
general let's say you're looking for
representation um if if what you're
sending out is not blazing hot you get
one shot with that agent or
manager
um if you're trying to sell something
and you know pitch it and sell it uh you
get the shot
the number of shots where you have the
number of meetings to sell it but I got
to tell you if you don't sell it because
it's not ready they're not likely to set
another meeting with you for another
project it's sad but it's true sure and
rather hear the the truth what if let's
say five years have gone by what if okay
someone was in a different life
situation or headp space and then
they've had a transformation and now
their story is so much more compelling
do they get that chance five years later
or is their name still in a database uh
there is no database there's just up
here who remembers people um well there
might be a database but if they've
written excuse me if they've written new
material and that material is a home run
blazing
hot they have another shot they really
do if they can get it to new people and
the truth is in this day and age
decision makers you know lower level
executives are moving around like crazy
including leaving the business so you
you'll be talking to somebody new most
likely okay so there's not it's not like
there's a file on you somewhere and then
they're going to pull it oh I remember
in 2017 and you said yeah I think we're
going to pass it so you can be a whole
new person really and Pitch something
yes but if there's people that remember
you it it's going to be you're going to
have to just kill it on your script so
they go wow they cannot deny you look at
how this person look how far they've
come and wow they really in five years
they learned they
grew um
yeah how does someone know that the
entertainment industry is right for them
you can do anything else I'm sure you've
had other people tell you this if
there's any other business that you can
do and be happy go do that because this
is such a tough
competitive totally rewarding but super
competitive business with lots of
rejection if you have a thick skin and
it's hard when you're an artist because
your art um my colleague Jeff melvoy in
the wga showrunner training program says
you like an Eminem a &m P you have to
have a a hard a candy shell but a soft
chocolate Center oh so that's the image
to think of you have to have your art
which is the soft chocolate but you have
to be able to withstand the business
which is the hard candy shell well there
are some people though that they thrive
on a challenge you know they get bored
easily usually because they're good at
everything and then they they just kind
of like no this is too easy and they
they Tire of it so it seems like too
that maybe someone in that head space
would it would be good to try I don't
know maybe they would get bored of
different things well if they're bored
because they're so successful like bless
them because they're they are a unicorn
because that's not how it generally
happens um but if somebody is willing to
take risks if somebody is willing to
withstand rejection and get back up if
somebody has
perseverance then this is the business
for them if if they have a driving
passion to tell a story or to tell
stories or to make a difference and
through entertainment I think people can
really make a difference in the culture
in the
conversation and if you're driven to do
that and you can deal with all the other
things the an things that go with it
then this is absolutely the business for
you ancillary like what
rejection
competitiveness
rejection having to get your 10,000
hours in having to
become excellent at what you are wanting
to do at what you're doing be Head and
Shoulders above everybody else that's
what it takes to stand
out and be easy to work with likable oh
yeah um you know do great in a room yes
that's not hard oh no that's easy um I
tell my daughter who and I didn't help
her get this job I promise you she's the
showrunner assistant on the show never
have I ever um her boss is the
showrunner on that show and she wants to
be a staff writer and I tell her and
every other young person that wants to
be a television writer you need to have
talent but Talent is not the most
important thing you have to have a
fantastic work ethic you have to have a
personality that people want to be
around that you're a pleasure you're
Pleasant to be around that work ethic is
I'll do whatever it takes and then some
you need to know people and you need to
continue to expand and grow your
community of mutually beneficial
relationships that's all the things in
your control that you have to do and
then luck and timing come into it
too wow because it seems
counterintuitive maybe that's the wrong
word but as being a writer and and
having stories and being in your head
all the time usually those come from
being away from people and actually
enjoying that they should be feature
writers they should write screenplays
for motion pictures cuz you get to be by
yourself when you do that but if you
have an interested in being in
television it is a collaborative
experience and you need to be able to
listen to other people's ideas add to
them not reject them and and be somebody
who's to use the word again additive and
somebody who's fun you you need to an
upbeat and doesn't take themselves too
seriously what if a writer knows they
want to write a b there's so many shows
they love to watch they want to be part
of it they want to be additive as you
said but they don't actually know what a
successful career looks like right a
successful career in order to if we're
talking about television in order to be
successful in television you need to be
able to have people who advocate for you
you can't just have your agent or
manager send your workout you need to
get alliances and you need people to say
when you're up for a show wow I've
worked with her or he's terrific I
mentored him and you need that so you
need a temperament that goes along with
making connections hopefully genuine
connections being of help to people
and not taking yourself too
seriously how does someone deprogram
themselves from that what if they don't
realize they take themselves
seriously if they don't realize that
they take themselves seriously they're
going to run into a brick wall People
based on their talent may give them a
shot once but they won't be invited back
and so the world will give them feedback
on that or if you have a lovely
generous showrunner or upper level
writer they'll take you aside and say
this is a problem
you're you're a downer and you you your
sense of self-importance is getting in
the way of you being a team player you
should only be so lucky to have somebody
like that we've all had teachers
probably in our lives that have been
wonderful and they have kind of taken
you under their wing with good
intentions and then we've also probably
all had the opposite and so if if we're
lucky to find someone that that can
maybe they see themselves in that
student or whatever and they they
genuinely want to help them there's no
ulterior motive well that's a teacher or
a mentor that's not
employment and that's a difference a
mentor or a
teacher if they're very generous if
they're Savvy they'll say you are
wonderful but your attitude is going to
sink you if we're talking about an
employment situation you have one shot
if there's a I I don't know whether I
said it in my book or someplace else but
there's a life is too short list and
even if you're successful if you're
annoying or difficult
or
awful as a person uh people won't want
to be in business with you because life
is Too Short if you're combative if you
don't take notes they'll remember
that okay what if you're none of those
things but you you freeze up in a room
you're actually probably a good person
inside but you just you have a hard time
in a mixer you have a hard time in a
ride well the thing I recommend to all
writers is take improv classes that will
help you stay present in the moment when
you're anxious it's because you're in
your head you're not in the moment
talking to somebody you're thinking what
are they thinking about me oh my God I'm
not saying the right thing improv is a
fantastic way to do that um another way
is there's some there used to be
something called Toast Masters um if
there still is go do that learn how to
speak in front of people um I had a
client who was so anxious in the room
and I gave her the name of a therapist
who does cognitive behavioral therapy
and he helped her get past it we talked
earlier about uh being tough and you
said that there was a showrunner or
someone that you knew who said kind of
like we're we have to be like M&M's I
like that analogy so hard candy shell on
the uh outside and then a nice chocolate
soft inside yes
um Can toughness ruin someone's writing
what if you've mastered that part but
you've also then lost yourself because
now you have this Teflon shell and the
Humanity's been pushed down so much you
have a problem the truth is you have a
problem that's good okay number one sure
and
um you need to figure
out how to get back to the thing that
got you excited about it in the first
place let's say you're a writer excited
about being a writer in the first place
and try and get back there um I think
you can ask your friends for help and
say you know what I've I've lost my
North Star here can do you have
suggestions on how on how I can get it
back I mean maybe you work with a coach
or something like that a therapist and
say this was great it helped me be tough
but as you said I've lost the artist of
in me and you need to get that back
maybe you go on an artist Retreat maybe
you take new classes you you just try
and get in touch with that part of
yourself again because just being tough
is is not going to do the job for you it
really is a fine line you have to walk
both of them sure then maybe you know
law or real estates for you right not
not not uh being a a show writer what if
your friends are all yes people they
don't want to tell you the truth find
new friends okay um you have to have
people that will tell you the truth you
really do
and it's so interesting because you want
people who will tell you the truth but
not people who are going to be me mean
who they have a vested interest in
pushing you down um that's why I go back
to a therapist or a coach a coach has
nothing invested in you except your
success and they can
say this is not working you you came to
me because you're having a problem and
this is what the problem is and let's
work on how we can fix it sure well
therapists still want to get paid though
that's well so do consult so do coaches
so yeah they want to continue the
relationship that is true you know what
I hadn't thought about that I was
thinking about myself as a coach I just
want them to get better there are people
who are just in it for themselves and
they're going to string you along so try
and find somebody who has your best
interests and want you to get to where
you need to go
quickly how do you know if you're a
Storyteller you love to tell stories
you've been telling stories since you
could talk you I have people that have
applied to my CBS program and they write
in their letter of interest I started
writing stories when I was 5 years old
or I watched somebody just did I watched
SpongeBob SpongeBob Square Pants and
then I wrote the ep the next episode of
what I wanted it to be and she was like
six so you know maybe you keep a journal
you are a writer you're a Storyteller if
you you love telling stories what do
great storytellers have in common they
have something they need to
express they want to Delight someone
they want to scare someone they want to
move
someone they want their story to make an
impact and that's how you know if you if
you have a burning desire to get your
story and story out there you're a
Storyteller what are the key elements of
a good story the key elements are you
care deeply about the characters and
that the story has unexpected turns
things happen in it that you wouldn't
have anticipated but they're still
within the world that the writer has
created but it always comes down to the
characters it's always about do we care
about them
do we love them or can we not turn away
because they're such a train
wreck it's the characters that we're
we're hardwired for story and the Heart
of a story is character and you can have
a great plot great plot but if there
isn't compelling characters to go with
it nobody cares how does a Storyteller
make their projects more
meaningful meaningful I I think the more
personal it is the more meaningful it is
if you're willing to tackle topics that
are meaningful that aren't just um this
is so mean but Emily and Paris fabulous
clothes you got to love the locations
but how meaningful is that really if if
if you're willing to
explore with depth you'll find
meaning and if you want to move people
with your work you will find stories
that are meaningful otherwise people
aren't moved sure sure yeah I mean but
it was a successful show and and you
know I watched it it didn't move me in
that way but it was a light it was very
light right we're talking about Emily
and Paris correct we all need
entertainment too especially during the
pandemic and we're just coming out of it
I I sometimes just still watch um Big
Bang Theory because I need to not think
about anything I and abbid Elementary I
adore because it's fun and Emily and
Paris is fun and it's eye candy but is
it deeply meaningful I don't think so
how does a Storyteller stay
authentic you constantly check in with
yourself with a no BS detector and when
you create something you say is this
true for me is this really true or am I
chasing the marketplace and whatever I
think people want is what I'm going to
give them if it's true for you then it's
authentic if now sometimes true for you
can be so Niche that other people can't
relate to it so
um that isn't always the best but check
in with yourself make sure that what
you're saying and the stories you're
telling that you care about them and
that's how you'll stay
authentic yeah I think that would be an
interesting dilemma is is how Niche is
your story and we all think our story is
relatable but um you know obviously not
and if the general audience is not in LA
not in New York those are going to be
different stories in some sense
absolutely then they may not relate to
it it needs to be Universal when I was
at CBS and this will show you how old I
am we did Murphy Brown the first Murphy
Brown and at the
time that Dian English came in to pitch
it the the word on the street was don't
do politics nobody can relate to
politics nobody cares outside the
Beltway but those characters were so
Charming so fun so engaging that
politics didn't matter so it's about the
characters do storytellers see the world
the same as everyone else I don't think
so I think storytellers have a Keen Eye
for what's beneath the
surface that's where the richness
is interesting you know they they talk
about um in books like the drama of the
gifted child things like that sometimes
upbringing makes you more uh aware of
things whether it's a survival it's it's
by by necessity um let's say someone had
a wonderful childhood and it's it's not
that but they just maybe were more
introspective maybe they were um an infj
or ENFJ or something they um to go Myers
Briggs on you yeah right they uh they
studied people storytellers study people
and look for truth if you you've been
unfortunate enough to have had a
traumatic experience growing up or
traumatic
childhood you probably know how to dig
deeper and you're you may not be afraid
of confronting that some people are and
they don't go there but some people who
have worked through their trauma can
bring it out in a story in a way that
other people can relate to it there's
some stories that are
so difficult to watch because they're so
raw but there's people who who want to
see that how do you know you've met a
Storyteller a
Storyteller is somebody that has a
interesting slightly off-kilter view of
the world that's how you can tell that
you're meeting a good Storyteller they
um they see things slightly differently
they are aware of emotions that not
everybody is can access and when I meet
those people I know it I know it and
also often they're rack on tours they
know how to tell a story with a
beginning middle and and hook me that's
one way to know you're talking to a
Storyteller leading with trauma hat it
okay hate it don't recommend it well
we're we're in a new you know I'm Gen X
so we didn't really do that we wanted to
make sure everything looked fluffy and
beautiful on the outside but we're in a
new age where I'm actually pleased to
see people are okay with different
things but I think we've become so much
so as I'm this and is that okay to do or
or is that a little bit too much too
soon let's let's wait till the second
date to talk about that I couldn't agree
with you more on the first date unless
you're a certain kind of person you're
not going to go into the depths of your
despair the depths of your trauma you
need to meet someone and see what their
ability to absorb that is if you just
lead with it that can be overwhelming
for people and and it can be a
turnoff what I say to people is because
it's so hard to listen to that's the
turnoff um what I tell people is if you
have worked through your trauma and you
can talk about it in a way that isn't
raw for you and you can almost this
isn't quite it but you can almost toss
it off and just say this is a thing that
happened so that the person listening
doesn't have to feel sorry for you then
talk about that if it's still so raw
that you're emotionally bleeding from it
don't go there don't go there it's it's
it's too vulnerable and people really
are put off I think by somebody
who's that raw some people love it but
most people will back away from
it is it easy for a great script to go
nowhere a great script a truly great
script if you have any connection to
anybody
in the entertainment industry who can
look at that and know it's a great
script it's going to go someplace you're
going to get you're going to get
recognized people will call you they'll
want to take you out for lunch or drinks
they'll want to um hire you to write for
them they'll want to um H be in business
with you in some way
a great script now if you are living in
Oshkosh and you don't know anybody and
you're not willing to submit your
scripts to
contests it could go nowhere but if
you're willing to get it out there in a
way that someone in the entertainment
industry would get eyes on it you will
go somewhere for
sure so if someone's script is not quote
unquote going anywhere is it safe to
assume it's not any
good well what I say is scripts need to
be blazing hot my first boss said that
writing is choices and when you have a
character who has to make a choice the
First Choice you come up with anybody
could come up with my dentist would come
up with the second choice pretty obvious
the third choice a little bit less and
then four five and six if you can push
yourself to there it's getting
better if you're at 8 nine and 10 and
not many people are 10 that you've
forced yourself to try 10 different
choices until you get to the very best
choice then that script is good but if
you're if you're at four or five and you
try four or five things and you said no
this this is this is good enough
then if it's been out there in the
marketplace for three or four or five
months it's not the marketplace it's
your script it's not ready and I
encourage you to either rewrite it or
write something else because every time
you write a new script it's going to get
better so it's not them it's me yes okay
and what we talked about earlier was
that when you meet a Storyteller you can
kind of tell that you know they see the
world in a very different way they're
very dialed in to little details and is
that where the the real beauty of a
Storyteller takes over is that that
taking it Beyond level four in terms of
how you know little nuances to the to
the script yes I think so great
storytellers are at
789 uh brilliant you know Aaron sorin 10
right but the rest of us humans you know
regular people it's not fair yeah seven
eight n you know that if you're willing
to bleed for it to get to seven eight or
nine then I think you're probably a
really good Storyteller what are the
best ways for a new writer to get
industry Pros to read their script
really good
question if you don't know anybody
there are first of all beware be really
wary
of coverage
Services they're not all made equally
you need to know who's reading your
script it could be a junior executive it
could be a
bartender and what I tell people is if
you are getting
coverage um only listen to what
resonates and if you re and be really
honest with yourself is that a good note
is that a note from somebody who doesn't
get what I'm doing at
all so one way is
contests um you don't have to know
anybody to enter your scripts into
contests and if you come in first second
or third in a prestigious contest agents
managers producers will find you if you
don't do do that there are services but
always check and see who is behind the
service what their real credits are and
if they've been doing something if they
were a reader for six months that's not
who you
want okay so having never entered a
contest would they say who some of the
industry professionals are or they say
have worked with but you don't actually
know the person's name can't check their
credit
you mean in a contest or coverage
service right if they're not telling you
then don't go there right yeah I'm
always wary of websites whatever
industry where you don't know the family
name or the person behind it even if
there's no picture but just to have a
general sense of who someone is behind
it that you're giving your money to yeah
if they're not willing to tell you who
they are they don't have to necessarily
give you a last name better if they do
but what that person's credentials are
if they're not willing to do that
specifically don't spend your money
there okay so what if a a new writer has
identified maybe five contests that are
definitely legit they see it on
screenwriting Twitter people are
discussing it should they continue to
enter them even if they haven't won and
they haven't gotten any favorable notes
back yes continue to write and get
better at at writing I've known people
for my CBS program that have applied
four times and it wasn't until the fifth
time that they got in because it wasn't
until the fifth year that their material
was good enough but if year after year
after year you're not getting any
traction then there's then you're
missing something and maybe you should
take a class Maybe you should do an
online course but again only reputable
ones don't waste your money on I always
like to say in terms of contest coming
in third place in the shmagi film
festival is going to do nothing for you
[Music]
um yeah push yourself to that seven
eight or nine sure sure yeah you can you
can check in on what screenwriters are
doing on on Reddit on LinkedIn um on
Twitter and so you see people who are
very proud that they've placed and and
to to follow suit I guess yeah um
fortune favors the Bold absolutely why
do you love this uh is this a saying or
a proverb yes it's a proverb and do I
remember who said it no but it is a
famous
saying this if you're not willing to
take a risk sell
insurance if you're willing to take a
risk if you're willing to To Boldly say
this is my vision I stand behind it I'm
putting in my 10,000 hours I'm going to
get better I have a story to tell and
I'm willing to do whatever it takes to
tell
it then interestingly the universe comes
along and gives you a push that's what I
think okay I like that uh what if there
are responsibilities you know you talked
about a a woman that you're working with
who who had a child to raise and
understandably had to put things on the
back burner for a while um how does
someone navigate that I I don't know I
guess it's specific for each situation I
think so but you know have a number of
clients in that
situation and we come up with a plan for
how they can get time in even if it's a
little time on a daily basis at 30
minutes a day and I know some writers
that get up 30 minutes early before
their kids get up I know some writers
that stay up 30 minutes later if their
brain is still
working if you do that and I say only
work four days a week I really believe
you need to have a life and in order to
write about something you need
creativity in to have creativity out and
just carve some time for yourself I know
it's really hard I don't mean to be flip
about it but 30 minutes even if it's 15
minutes a day you will find yourself
making
progress okay what if someone is lucky
enough to have that time but they feel
selfish we we talked to another uh both
writer and Mom and there is a
connotation sometimes that it's
selfish that what I'm doing is is is you
know why why am I doing this I should be
taking care of someone
else
codependent um read Melody Bey okay
right read Melody Bey for that
codependence
okay you have to find the strength
inside
yourself that says I deserve this I
don't mean leave your children in the
street but carve out 30 minutes you have
to find inside yourself the essential
you that yearns to be an artist and say
I'm going to devote some of my time and
energy on a regular basis to that um I
just saw the documentary Judy Bloom
forever
and she had to ultim I'm not suggesting
this but she had to ultimately leave her
husband because he didn't want her to
pursue her craft don't leave your
husband don't leave your wife I'm not
saying that sure I'm saying it's good to
surround yourself with people that
support you in your in your desire oh I
want to see that movie I did not I love
Judy Bloom so it's a documentary
actually okay right and that just came
out just came out wow cuz now her her
are you there God it's me Margaret yeah
came out do will well yeah that's a
that's a tough uh comedic uh it is you
know not everyone's going to get some of
the humor there things like that but um
that was that's a landmark book for it
ABS many many people is and was and is
still is yeah yeah and has been
banned so but I I want to I want to see
that documentary that's good I like that
what is the general timeline for getting
a screenplay read if you're a new writer
and you're sending it out to
professionals yep
okay here's what I say first of all I
have a pet peeve that I want to share
with the people who are watching this do
not ask somebody you've just met to read
your script it I did a Blog about
Hollywood etiquette don't do that
because I just want people to think
about this you're asking me a person
that you don't know and I don't know you
to take 2 hours out of my life away from
my family and my work to read your
script wait until you know somebody so
please please please don't say nice to
meet you will you read my script but
let's say you have been able to put it
in the hands of somebody who is in the
industry what I say is give people six
weeks to start and then reach out to
them every month after that every 3 or
four weeks weeks and always be
respectful and say I know how busy you
are I just wanted to Circle back and see
if you've had an opportunity to read it
and if not no worries I'll check back in
again in another month I know somebody
who gave it to a
showrunner and it took that showrunner a
year to read it but she finally did and
she gave her feedback but if you've been
reaching out to people and don't annoy
them just do do it regularly but not
annoyingly and if they haven't responded
to you in a
year stop reaching out and find somebody
else what about if someone sends it to
someone or or emails someone and says I
know you know so and so fill in the
blank can you get it to that person now
you're asking that person to risk that
relationship their reputation breaking
protocol yeah that is the same thing as
asking somebody to read your script you
ask me to give it to I have a funny
story if you want to hear it I do yeah
okay my friend Doug who I hired at amlin
which is Steven Spielberg's company was
at his grandmother's funeral and he was
walking back to the car with the rabbi
and the rabbi said I have a script in my
car could you please give it to Stephen
oh don't do
that don't do that okay
um you're asking me if you say will you
get it to so and so I don't know you to
use up one of my chits to you to to use
up one of my
credibility
chits don't do that you're asking too
much now if I meet you and we have a
relationship and I really like you I'll
ask you to read your script let me read
your scpt script and if the script is
fabulous I will pass it along don't ask
me to pass it along but if I love it let
me tell you I'm going to pass it along
because it makes me look good I
discovered this person but you don't ask
you let it
happen wow what ended up happening in
that situation or is that too
personal no she got
wrapped with the the person whose Rabbi
asked oh nothing
happened nothing happened right because
Doug would no more take that person's
script and give it to Stephen his boss
then he would walk on the moon what
happened is that Doug would not hire
that Rabbi to do his grandfather's
funeral if we put together a list of how
not to break in to the entertainment
industry what would five things be
five how not to get work how not to get
work by Carol kersner five ways don't
put in the time to develop your
craft don't reach out to people to find
out if they know someone who could
introduce you not a decision maker but
just somebody that might be
willing to meet with you zoom coffee for
10 or 15 minutes somebody who does not
want to enlarge their community of
relationships um something else not to
do is don't be a jerk and we were just
talking about this don't ask somebody
you don't know to read your script or
get your script to Steven Spielberg or
somebody else
um don't be
generous you need to be generous there's
so many generous generous people in this
business the perception is everybody's
like this but somebody helped them so if
you approach them
correctly and you are humble and you are
respectful they'll give you 15 minutes
of their time unless they're a jerk and
there certainly are jerks
um don't be
annoying is that more than five that's
more than five that's okay I'm enjoying
this yeah okay well and I like what you
say and the thing is is that I think
these relationships they take time and
so we're in such a fast world right that
it it can't just be you meet someone at
a mixer yes get their card or their
contact info and now you have this ask
yes what I say and this I firmly believe
in first of all I hate the word
networking it makes me feel icky to even
say it I like the word
connecting if you make a genuine
connection with somebody
then follow that up
um don't ask somebody for
something when you don't know them think
about if you were working and somebody
said to you I know you got a full-time
job but will you do X for me it'll only
take you an hour and a half
um I always say and this is in my book
it's in my blogs it's the correct
Hollywood ask you ask somebody for
something but you give them a gracious
way out so you might say I know you're
incredibly busy but would you have the
time to do X if you have the time would
you do X is there somebody I know how
busy you are is there somebody in your
office that would be willing
to X look at my script give me some
thoughts on it um when you ask somebody
to read your script don't ask ask them
for detailed notes just say I'd love
your general opinion of it cuz that
makes it just an hour read instead of a
2hour Endeavor because nobody in the
entertainment industry wants to say no
to you because they don't know unless
they're a jerk again they're are jerks
they don't want to say no to you because
someday they may be working for you or
looking for a job from you so make it so
that it's easy for them to decline if
they have to what are the assumptions
most new writers get wrong about the
business that everybody's
awful that nobody wants to help them and
that's often because they don't know how
to do what we talked about the soft
Hollywood
ask that it's easy I think that's a big
assumption that newcomers have that it's
easy they read a story about one person
who made it like that and they think
that's going to be them um they assume
they don't have to do a lot of work that
somebody will like them enough that
they'll go okay you keep yeah I like you
I'm going to hire you and and let you
get better while I pay you that would be
a bad
assumption what are some common excuses
you hear from new writers whether
they're bad at pitching themselves or
you know things about the entertainment
industry that are that you see you know
what you're you're putting up roadblocks
you're you're making
excuses if you're
bitter and you don't like people and you
think everybody's out to get
me that will not help you if you
think I'm just in it for what I can get
and not how I can help
somebody that's a problem because that
generosity of spirit goes so far it
really
does I always say be kind there's no
downside to being kind and you never
know who you're going to be kind to who
later on will go wow that person was
kind I want to help them sure I'm I'm
all for kindness but you can also be
stepped on and taken advantage of true
don't be a
doormat don't be a doormat it is having
confidence without being a
jerk it is having a belief in yourself
without being
annoying and when you have
that you can think about how you can
help somebody else and not get stepped
on and you have to have self-esteem this
business it it may feel like it's kind
of wearing you down but you have to have
self-esteem in order to put yourself out
there in order to sell something in
order to sell
yourself I think a small bit of delusion
helps though because if you're too aware
of the odds you'll never do anything
here's what I say people break in every
day why not
you and that's what you should tell
yourself somebody's breaking in today
why not me well it may be because you
haven't done the work it may be because
something else but if you have and
you're truly
ready why not you keep that in
mind and you mentioned bitterness and
although that word is is definitely a
negative I think there's a healthy sense
of putting up some boundary sure because
if you're too open and you're
too fresh off the bus and you think this
is all wonderful and and take things at
face value you're going to learn very
quickly that's not how it is
you you
should be mindful you should read the
room read the business and not lead with
your heart on your sleeve that doesn't
help you it need you need to make sure
that it's sort of a safe place to do
that
and I think that if you're a puppy dog
oh my oh my oh my
um that will not serve you but if you're
genuinely enthusiastic with
confidence that will serve you people
love passion and enthusiasm but if
you're oh my look at me look at me look
at me look at me that's going to be a
problem a vetted writer versus an
extremely talented writer which one is
going to succeed the vetted writer
because you have to have a level of
talent in order for people to want to
help you to recognize your talent
somebody with raw
talent let me tell you Talent is
important but it's not the most
important thing it's whether people want
to help you whether you are generous I
talked about generous it's whether
you're meeting enough people it's about
do you have the right work ethic it's do
people want to be around you the most
brilliant writer isn't
necessarily the one that's going to get
traction you need all the other parts of
the business the other parts of the
whole in order to succeed raw talent is
a fabulous place to start but you have
to know what the business is and know
what else is
needed what are the different ways a
writer can find an agent it's a question
I get asked all the time and there are a
number of ways one is enter a contest
and come in
first um if you're
quarterfinalist that's not going to do
anything um and as I said before if
you're a quarterfinalist in thei film
festival nobody is looking at that if
you are in a very prestigious cont
competition and you come in first or
second agents and managers will find you
and the annoying thing is is that agents
say when you say how does somebody get
an agent they say don't worry when
you're ready we'll find you and there's
a lot of Truth in that no matter how
annoying it is so that's one another way
is if it's television and you can get
into one of the network
fellowships they will introduce you to
agents and
managers if you can find a mentorship
program they will introduce you to their
um agents or managers if
you do a one woman one man one person
show and you put it up it has a
fantastic reaction that's how flea bag
came
about they'll find you um another way
my daughter who's a comedy writer an
aspiring comedy writer one of her best
friends did a video that went viral and
she was repped within a week and they
keep inviting her to go back to Saturday
Night Live and apply to be a writer
there so if you make a Big Splash in
social media that is a way to do it um
knowing somebody who knows somebody who
can get your script to to an agent or
manager or an agent or manager's
assistant is one way to do it I used to
say don't bother with this but cold
queries can work I've now had three
mentees and a client who wrote fabulous
letters cold queries
emails and they made their themselves so
appealing and the log line for one of
their script so appealing that the
manager or agent said I'd like to read
your script and then they had a meeting
with them because the script was so good
and they got repped another way is and
this is hard if you're not in the
business is to have a job working in the
business even if it's as a PA somewhere
because you'll meet somebody who will
know somebody who will know somebody who
will know somebody who can get your
script in front of of an agent or a
manager another way is to have a podcast
these days podcast wow that is super
successful they'll find you um the
easiest way is to already be making
money as a screenwriter because agents
love to poach their competitions uh
clients and those are the ways those are
the ways so with the people that queried
and these letters out how did they know
the names and where did they find the
contact information how they actually
get the contact information IMDb Pro has
contact information for agents and
managers I recommend that people look
for a manager first there's so many more
of them than there are agents and the
ones just starting out are often willing
to take newbies and and sort of invest
in them and one way to do it is to look
at your favorite movie your favorite
television
shows go to IMDb look up their name and
see who represents them and then go to
that person's contact page and that's
how you do it what should a new writer
expect from a meeting with an agent in a
meeting if you're hot commodity the
manager or agent it's like being on a
date when somebody wants to get you in
bed they will tell you anything how
beautiful you are how handsome you are
how much they love
you what you should be thinking about in
that meeting if you're a hot commodity
is ask them very clearly where do you
see my career in 5 years and how will
you help me get there the thing to
remember is if you go with this person
they work for you you want to make sure
that they've read your material and they
get who you are they really understand
who you are as a writer and they get
your Vibe and that your Vibes match um
you may not you may want a super
aggressive agent or that may not be your
style and you want somebody who's super
hardworking and ambitious but not super
aggressive you can expect them to ask
you what you want in a relationship with
a manager you can expect them to ask who
do you know in the business because the
more people you know the easier it is
for them to do their job they might ask
you what are your favorite shows what
are your favorite movies they may ask
you what is your sweet spot as a writer
what do you like to write what are you
great at writing they will definitely
ask you what else do you have in your
portfolio besides what they read for you
to get to that
meeting that's probably about it they'll
they'll make small talk to get you to
now that's if you're hot commodity um
and it's all your choice because you're
meeting with five different managers and
you get to decide it's really who you
Vibe with and who has a track record in
getting their clients
work if if you're new and you're not yet
a hot
commodity you should be prepared to tell
them what else you have in your
portfolio you should be prepared to tell
them what your career Ambitions are you
should be prepared to tell them who you
know in the business and the ways that
you meet people they're going to want to
know that you should be prepared to ask
them who are your other clients that I
might talk to um they may take umbrage
at that and if they do that's not the
person for you um you should be prepared
to ask
them how do they see you getting to the
next level in your career and how can
they help you do it they may ask you how
often how long does it take you to write
a script and be prepared to be honest
with that answer so unlike a first date
where you wouldn't say you know when
when are we setting our
wedding in in an agent meeting you would
be very upfront about this is what I
expect and what can I expect from you
would that be a little bit too fast too
soon well you don't probably have a lot
unless you're that hot commodity you
don't have a lot of shots with an agent
or manager you probably have one meeting
with them I'm not suggesting you come in
guns Blaze aming I think you come in and
you're complimentary to them and you say
you know I would love to work with you I
it would be fantastic I'd love to ask
you a couple of questions and say it in
a humble way but ask those
questions okay so there's direction to
the meeting it's not just you're showing
up and you have an actual plan yes you
want to think ahead now
sometimes and it's not very of this may
just be a meet and greet get to know you
see what they think of you um and it's
not what we call a signing meeting it's
really just a get to know you they read
something of yours they liked it they
they want to know more about you and
then it's really about having a
relationship a conversation with them
like you would with a friend or a new
person who you wanted to be friends with
but if it turns to business be prepared
to ask ask those questions okay have
that in your back pocket absolutely what
are some red flags a new writer should
be aware of when meeting with an agent
if the person is a
jerk if they haven't read
you if they're blowing
smoke if they're not transparent about
the type of people they
represent if they're late to the meeting
if they talk at you the whole time if
they're just being blustery if they
don't ask you about yourself and again
if they haven't read your work if they
don't have an opinion about your
work these are red flags how do we know
someone's blowing smoke if they tell you
you're fabulous you're fabulous you're
fabulous and you've only written one
script they're probably blowing smoke if
they say oh yeah I can get you meeting
with Spielberg I can get you a meeting
with JJ Abrams you need to that's a red
flag because they don't know you enough
yet and if they could get you those
meetings you're probably not meeting
with the people that can get you those
meetings when you're starting
out talking at someone versus talking
with them yes H pet
peeve they just talk about themselves
it's a wall of words they talk talk talk
they don't give you any time to they
never take a breath for you to say
something they're just talking about
themselves and they're talking nonstop
and they're not making eye contact and
they're not pausing and they're not
reading the room they don't care about
you so they're not you you see they're
not picking up on social cues right okay
they take themselves so seriously they
love the sound of their voice that's not
somebody who's gonna help you because if
they're that way with you they're going
to be that way with decision makers and
that turns decision makers off what if
an agent rejects a writer that's sad but
move on to the next
one but we're sensitive artists Carol we
we we we feel things this was our big CH
painful it's
painful um I worked at a job where my
contract didn't get picked up for a
second part of it I was so devastated I
ate ice cream for days I bought shoes I
felt
terrible and then I moved on and my
husband has a great way of looking he
said wallow in it wallow in your pain
wallow in the disappointment give
yourself three days to feel no stay in
bed watch stupid
television and then move on and then
move on
unless you want to give up forever right
then and don't do that this is part of
the
business feel it acknowledge it
experience
it give yourself the space to do that
and then move on to the
next what makes an executive hire a
writer well there's a couple of
different things that they would hire
them
for if somebody is pitching a show I
mean my expertise is primarily
television but a lot of this applies to
Motion Pictures also to
Features if someone is pitching it and
they nail the
pitch they're going to want to be in
business with them if there's somebody
who if an executive is in charge of
finding writers to be on a television
show if you have a meeting with that
person they want to know that you're not
a psycho they want to they will have
read you and they will think this is a
terrific writer now let me see if I can
get along with them let me see if the
showrunner I'm thinking of for the show
they would be right for would get along
with them those are the reasons why
somebody would hire that's why an
executive would hire a
writer what are the most important
elements of a pitch well it's
interesting because pitching is an art
it's not a science and I have an online
course called how to pitch a TV show
that sells and we talk all about this
but the important elements are the
characters that's super important how
the characters are going to grow and
change over the pilot and then over the
series people think that the pilot story
is the most important thing and it's not
because you're not just selling a pilot
you're selling a series so it is what
the hook is that's super important why
are people going to watch it why are
they going to watch it now why will it
stand out from 500 plus other scripted
television shows you got to have a
strong
hook then it's tell me about the world
also it's really important in a pitch
and you talk about this earlier in in
another video
is having a personal story that ties you
to that project it's not like you just
said oh wouldn't it be funny if uh there
was a roller coaster and it was haunted
you have to and I'm a terrible I'm not a
writer which is why I just gave that
terrible example um but you have to
connect with it somehow when I was Home
Alone one night I was sure that a ghost
was there and I was terrified and I
thought what if somebody is terrified of
that and terrify it on a roller coaster
too find a way to make an emotional
connection with find that emotional
connection in the project and use that
to connect with the buyer if you tell an
authentic emotional story they will be
hooked in so it's the hook it's what I
call your inspiration story why you why
this project it is talking about the
characters why they're unique why we
haven't seen them before it's about the
world what does that world look like you
want to paint it you want us to feel it
tell us why we want to be immersed into
it for 40
hours super important what is the engine
of the show if it's a TV
show why does this have legs past just
the pilot and and season arcs are really
important and knowing what that is and
then you have something that I call the
Kota which is a concluding remark where
you go back to your hook and then you
say why people will watch it why it's
timely why it's Universal why now how
long is a pitch to an executive what
should a writer think about in
preparation great
question some people think it goes on
forever it doesn't if you're pitching
television a comedy pitch should be 12
to 15 minutes long a
onour drama or 1eh hour show it should
be 20 to 25 minutes no longer unless
your Shan Ryan who just sold agent night
you know night agent um 20 to 25 minutes
and on Zoom should be shorter you should
rehearse your pitch you should time your
pitch you should come in on those times
and the again the pilot story is only a
very small portion of that 10 to 15 10
to 12 minutes or 20 to 25 minutes and
and record yourself giving the pitch as
absolutely so you can kind see and I
know somebody was a terrific pitch and
what she said is and this is what I
believe you write out the pitch word for
word then you transcribe it into bullet
points and then you practice using the
bullet points some people read their
pitch if you're a good performer you can
read your pitch but make it sound
conversational a good pitch is
conversational for
sure um so write it practice it record
yourself so that you can hear the pacing
in it so you've got that right so you
can time it I had a mentee in my CBS
program who was fantastic in my program
you have to introduce yourself 16 times
because there's 16 weeks and people got
to the point the writers got to the
point where it sounded totally rehearsed
but
Bradley had a way to make it sound like
it was the first time ever every time
and the way he did it is he would say
something and then he'd pause for a beat
as if he was actually thinking about
what the next thing was he was going to
say and he had some funny parts to a
story and he would chuckle a little bit
you know not like out laugh out loud but
you know just kind of chuckle so that
they could chuckle with him and his
introductions always sounded like they
were off the cuff you want this to sound
like it's off the cuff but you you know
it backwards and
forwards so with he's he's telling a
little bit about himself and then the
pitch well Bradley wasn't pitching that
that was
just it's a 16-week program and every
week I bring in different speakers and
the writers have to just introduce
themselves to each of the speakers I'm
sorry if that was confusing no no that's
I find that interesting okay so they're
kind of practicing that that because we
all don't really want to talk about
ourselves sometimes so it's like hi I'm
so and so and this is my deal and is is
that it so you're comfortable kind of
owning who you are yes I teach them I
mean that's one of the things I teach is
your entertainment industry brand and
you need to know how to talk about
yourself in a way that is engaging and
gets people leaning forward and wanting
to know more so I teach that to the
mentees in the Paramount writers
mentoring program and over 16 weeks they
hone it and hone it and hone it so that
by the end of the 16 weeks they can talk
about themselves like that and Bradley
was just a champ at it what are some
common mistakes that you see in
pitches o I love that question because
there's so many mistakes that people
make sadly it's sad when you make this
mistake is not being prepared is going
in and thinking I can wing it now here's
the truth there's some standup Comics
there's
some improv people that really can but
unless you're that person you can't you
should be they're not prepared enough
the other is going beat by beat by beat
of the pilot story I there's a sad story
that I like to tell from when I was an
executive a very wellestablished comedy
writer came in and pitched to us and he
was talking about the pilot story and he
was going beat by beat by beat and my
colleague fell asleep it was
horrifying um and he said to my boss the
writer said to my boss he fell asleep
and my boss said no no he's just resting
his eyes so he can hear you better but
that's something you don't want to do go
beat by it's it's overview you want to
give the big picture not every single
scene what's the difference between
telling versus sell in I have a mantra
that I believe in so strongly it's tell
don't
sell if you're desperate if you're there
just to sell the project chances are
really good you won't what you should be
there to do is to tell an engaging
exciting funny or moving story and what
I tell people is pretend that you're
talking to a 5-year-old
your whole vibe should be once upon a
time not well this is about this but
once upon a time in a forest there
was that's how you know you're telling
and selling is oh man I got to tell you
this is the best thing you ever heard of
and it's going to be great and don't do
that it's a terrible idea so add an
element of performance absolutely okay
but even if you're not not a natural
born performer and I do talk about this
in my class if you know your material
well enough and you're comfortable
enough you'll be able to talk about it
as if you were talking to a friend and
you don't need to do
B just you're yourself but it's like
you're talking to friends and you're
comfortable and it's upy and it's
engaging that's all you need to
be modesty versus Bragg in I this is a
tough one for people we all think we're
being modest sometimes we don't come
across that way to people how do we know
how do we know people are perceiving us
as this brager or humble bragging or or
the worst a do gooder on social media
but it's really
self-serving
yes it's so hard being a supermodel
that's that's not what you want to do
um you need to have friends that can
give you honest feedback another thing
is you're going to get feedback from the
world if people are leaning in that
means that you're saying something they
want to hear they like you or they're
interested in you if people are leaning
back it means that you're a jerk or
you're boring and I once heard a
Hollywood executive say one of the
biggest sins in Hollywood is being
boring punishable by
nonemployment so don't be boring don't
be a brager and and you'll know because
people will be turned
off okay so you'll pick up the cues
hopefully hopefully you do if you keep
meeting people and nothing good happens
you should check with some friends and
look into yourself and see what am I
doing what is a personal log
line well to me to me your entertainment
industry brand has three things a
personal log line which answers the
question what do you do it's about 30 or
40 seconds long the answer and you would
use it at a party or a networking event
or if you met somebody in an elevator
and it says who you are it says what you
like to write I work with writers
primarily although work with directors
too um um it it highlights what makes
you memorable it's something about you
that the three people standing next to
you can't say because it's your story um
and it's what you like to write and um
it's why you're good at it without being
a jerk um little bit about you know it's
it's very brief that one's brief there's
something called your personal a story I
call it that which is is when somebody
says so tell me about yourself that is a
bigger answer than what do you do and in
Hollywood everybody wants to know what
you do but the truth is they want to
know what you can do for them but you
should have an answer to what do you do
um so your personal a story is the
answer to the question tell me about
yourself and every meeting you have if
somebody doesn't know you they're going
to ask you to tell them about yourself
it's about about a minute and a half to
2 minutes long the answer and the answer
is it's a chronological narrative of
your life with you as the
protagonist it emphasizes your successes
and What Makes You
memorable and the narrative through line
is where you started what you had to
overcome to get to where you are where
you are and what you want to do next and
it's all
conversational wow okay so how much
oversharing are we doing though with the
overcoming because I know we're in a
space of now being very transparent
about many things don't be too personal
don't and and here's a real bottom line
don't make the person who's listen to
stop to feel sorry for you CU that gets
them out of the flow and you'll never
never get them
back good good point there okay so
and we're we're doing this in a fun with
a we're keeping it light it's a fun
twist we're not going to keep it you
know when you say
overcome should I just say and I had to
overcome Bad Hair Days in high school
like keep it maybe or you could say you
know what I grew up in poverty and I had
to work really hard to get somebody to
let me read a book this isn't it of
course and it all depends on how you say
it you know and it really is good to
sprinkle in I was so fortunate you know
I grew up in poverty and nobody in my
family ever thought you could make a
living as a writer but I was so
fortunate because I had a sixth grade
teacher who told me I was a Storyteller
that I could write and so I pursued that
and I got to
but again we're keeping it a beat we're
not yes we're not making the we're not
putting this guilt on the person
receiving our story right guilt or
feeling sorry for you
or doing that okay don't make them do
that okay great to know and and we're
peppering in fun little facts about
ourselves yeah you know I'm Karen I came
here to write the next Little Miss
Sunshine yeah okay I came here to rent
write the
next little sunshine and I was surprised
that I ended up having to clean up
disaster areas do you know what I mean
oh that's Sunshine Cleaning that's a a
good no it absolutely is but that's a
good one that I love that Amy Adams
Little Miss
Sunshine Girl the in the pageants with
Greg caner right right exactly um it
should be engaging now you may not be a
comic you may not be a funny person you
don't have to be you need to be engaged
engaging just make sure that they're
engaged in what you have to say and say
it in a way that feels authentic you can
be passionate about it and just use your
storytelling skills this time the story
you're telling is about yourself which
is just as important as telling a story
in a
script how self effacing should we be
let's not be a bragger we don't want to
say yeah it was so hard you know all
these guys wanted to date me and things
like that that's going to turn people
off but how much of quote putting
yourself down is also a turn off don't
put yourself down you never need to put
yourself down what you can do if you
want to talk about your accomplishments
here's an inside tip is say I was so
fortunate that I won that contest I was
thrilled when I found out that my script
made it on The
Blacklist I was so excited when I
discovered that I knew Paul Newman
that's such an old reference that I knew
I would still use that yeah good thank
you um that I knew uh Steven Spielberg
sure you
know that's how you take the sort of
stink off of saying your accomplishments
but don't put yourself down that is not
attractive think about going on a date
with somebody if they're that's not self
effacing that's like
being so humble to the point you're
putting yourself down that's not
attractive you're you're in a meeting
and it's like a date
it's I want to know that you think well
of yourself not to the point that you're
obnoxious but that you have confidence
think about a date you want somebody
who's confident being honest about
oneself without being crass right um
read the room if you're working in a
nightclub there are things you can say
that you shouldn't be saying in a 10
a.m. meeting with a current
executive um read the room you can push
it a little bit you can be sort of
surprising without being like e do you
know what I mean or that you offend
somebody don't be offensive that that
should be like the first rule don't be
offensive you
know just don't be offensive sure so
read the room so if you're going into a
um sort of a mixer and it's at a bar
that's one thing if you're going to sort
of a PTA meeting you're not going to be
using the same humor exactly exactly
what's the unspoken Hollywood dress
code casual but professional do not go
into a meeting with a suit in unless you
want to be an agent nobody wears and
even agents don't wear suits anymore it
should be clean it should be if if if
you're somebody who has interesting
clothes that's great but not something
that's you know like you're going to a
cocktail party this is like a meeting
um casual but know that this is not
really a casual business it looks casual
but it's a business so you know you
might wear a sport coat if you're a guy
or somebody that likes to wear coats
sport coats um but I wouldn't wear a tie
with it no and I also wouldn't wear like
a Shabby T-shirt with a hole in it don't
do that don't wear anything that has
like questionable writing on
it right okay so your mom says hi is
probably not a good
and you're not sure the humor is going
to be received at that right okay but
you know what if you're a comedy writer
though you're still taking yourself
seriously enough to wear something
presentable yeah but if you're a comedy
writer and you do have a t-shirt that's
not offensive but it's
funny make sure it's funny to everybody
right that's true that's true you can
wear that okay good to know and I say if
you're somebody that wears jewelry wear
something really interesting that's sort
of a conversation
starter what if a writer believes that
Hollywood has not created anything new
in the last 20 years anything
original and that a lot
of I mean awful is is a strong word but
they have sort of a bitterness towards
the writing and they feel like Hollywood
won't give them a
chance they're not going to get a chance
with that
attitude um if you feel like nothing
good has been written in 20
years who wants to talk to
you who who and you feel that your thing
is the best thing that's been written in
20 years you're probably delusional and
people will run in the other
direction what if someone wants to write
something a little more conservative and
they feel that their values don't line
up find a place where your values will
line up find the outlet where your
values will line up look at what
that
company has produced and go towards the
place where they're making content that
feels like it shares your values what
mindset or attitude should a writer
have
optimistic excited without being
annoying um interested interested in the
other person um feeling
like they are some great things out
there it it speaks to what you said
before what if you think nothing good
has been
written they think there's some great
content and they say that's the kind of
content I want to make so the attitude
is one of possibility of optimism of
being upbeat again without being
annoying of being interested of being
passionate okay we're friendly but we're
not polyana friendly
without being your best friend do you
know what I mean don't do that don't
don't assume that this person wants to
be friends with best friends with you
yeah that's interesting it's like a date
it's like a date how does someone show
they a leader without speaking
it by how you carry yourself by your
confidence again confidence not
not bragger not
obnoxiousness um somebody who has quiet
confidence somebody who's
decisive you know would you like water
or a Diet Coke I'll have the water
please even just that if you go
um um I no that no that's not
leadership you had talked about
something in in some of your either
course notes or something that you know
showing an attitude that the person's a
team player well how do we see that
because if I say I'm a team player you
can't say player okay
[Music]
um it's by having a sense of selfworth
that's what you have to come in with
have boundaries be friendly but not
again a puppy dog um and if you're
interested in somebody else with not to
the detriment of you but if you have the
confidence to be interested in somebody
and ask about them and also talk about
yourself which is a fine line and
sometimes hard
um somebody may see you interact with
somebody else you're going to order a
coffee or a drink and you're a b word or
a s word or any other kind of word and
they here's another thing speaking about
that how you treat assistance says so
much about you if you I when I was
hiring somebody when I was at ambling
this person came in he was mean to my
assistant he never even had a chance he
was really qualified but he didn't have
a chance so it's how you treat other
people again without being snively and
and and sort of rolling over and saying
please please please but I have
something to offer and I think you'll
like it you may not that's okay too um
in the in the most positive kind of a
way how does someone show they're a team
player oh how do you show your a team
player by listening to other team
players are people that listen to other
people and they add something to what
that person said that elevates what that
person said they chip in they're willing
to be part of a group and their their
mindset is how can I help this group how
can I add to this how can I be additive
you know we hear you have to know the
right people in the entertainment
industry how do you identify who the
right people
are the right people are people who
respond to who you are they're people
that have some Authority there're people
who can make things happen there's
people who have relationships with other
people they may be decision makers those
are the right people they're people who
know decision makers in a positive way
they're people who want to lift you up
that's the right
people once you identify the right
person or people how do you meet them
the girl great news is there's social
media you can go to events I mean now
that the pandemic is sort of kind of in
the rearview mirror there are Live
Events Again The Writers Guild of
America Foundation I I mean we're in the
middle of a strike right now so nothing
is going to happen then but when the
strike is over they have live inperson
panels and you can go think about
meeting peers people at your level
rather than I've got to go rush and talk
to the speaker meet people at your level
they'll come up with you at the same
time um events social media you can if
if there's somebody who you would like
to meet and they're on social media you
can like what they post you can repost
it or retweet it you can make a comment
about it like I really love
the episode about the freight train and
then you say you know I grew up on a
freight train it really was authentic
you can do that and if you do that
enough they'll get to know who you are
and you might DM them and say I'm such a
huge fan of yours and I'm an aspiring
writer if you ever had 15 minutes for a
zoom coffee I'd love to hear about your
journey and maybe get some advice now
you can't do that with somebody that's
up here do that with lower and midlevel
people you don't need to meet the
president of the studio you just need to
meet some people who are in farther than
you are and again it takes time it's not
yes it's it's not follow someone and
then hey ask them hey I'm a writer will
you read my script we talked about that
don't ask people to read your script
until you have a true Rel relationship
with them I know you don't like the word
networking you said connecting mhm okay
that's that's a great alternative what
else should a new writer know about
connecting you should have your story so
that when somebody says what do you do
you can answer that in a interesting way
you should know who you're going to be
meeting with if you possibly can and do
some research about them so you you
should be open and
friendly and be interested in the other
person again not step all over yourself
but it should be 70% about them and 30%
about you ask about them now there's
somebody who will start talking and
never stop talking about themselves go
say excuse me I have to get a drink and
leave but for most people be interested
in other people that goes think about
the people you know who are friendly and
have a lot of friends they are
interested in other
people that's what you want to do when
you're connecting and you want to look
for a genuine connection and if it's not
there that's okay go on to the next
person we all feel stuck at times what
do we do if we're just not creative
we're not on all cylinders
right there's a couple of different ways
to get
unstuck um I actually Teach an online
course about getting stuck and we talk
about if you're stuck because you have
writer's block or
procrastination there's
actual tips and tools that you can use
to get past it and one of them is to
give yourself very short periods of time
to work 10 minutes set a timer you can
either do free writing you could say I
like that butterfly but and then when
the timer goes off get up and go
someplace else and then the next day
come back for 10 minutes or 30 minutes
and the other is really to be clear
about what your true goals are and then
make sure everything you're choosing in
your life how you're spending your time
is moving you towards that goal it's
super important and then it's looking at
what's getting in the way of you
achieving your goals and seeing what you
can change how you can adjust your life
so that you're moving towards your goal
more
efficiently there's debate is writer's
block real
yeah it is it's
fear it's fear of failure it's fear of
success it's fear of impostor
[Music]
syndrome I've had too many clients that
had it to say it's not
real I don't know who's saying that but
my experience is that people truly are
blocked but you can absolutely get
unblocked that is really
possible and how much of being stuck is
burnout some of it is burnout some of
stuckness is burnout and if that's what
it is you need to take a break go to the
mountains go to the seashore go camping
um walk in the woods uh be with friends
who you like and cherish and who love
you um be in nature I know I said that
15 times I think that's really important
step away for a little bit do things
that are fun recharge your
batteries um and don't keep pressing on
yourself to go forward forward forward
if you're burned out take it's it's
about self-care you have to take care of
yourself you have to eat right you have
to exercise you have to get enough sleep
I don't know how you can be creative if
you're not getting enough sleep and
sometimes you have to work two jobs I
understand it but whatever you can do to
take care of yourself really helps to
combat
burnout and staying off social media for
a while what a great idea go on a social
media diet take a Hiatus because all
you're going to see are people that you
see they're succeeding God darn it why
aren't I and the pressure is too intense
tense absolutely take a holiday from
social media I couldn't agree with you
more when people come to you to take the
course what are some of the biggest
reasons they've become
stuck really good question they're not
able
to write new material or good material
they feel burned out they are afraid
they're afraid they'll never write again
they're afraid they'll never get another
job job they're
concerned
that they don't know enough people and
they don't know how to meet enough
people they're stuck they're stuck in
their career they don't know how to
reach out and ask for help they don't
know what it takes to meet people to to
they don't know their brand and so they
keep having these opportunities and they
blow their opportunities because they
don't know how to talk about themselves
and and is that off-putting then if if
they're because they're they're
struggling with kind of coming up with
who they are that it's not that it's
offputting but you're missing an
opportunity for somebody to be invested
in you and interested in you they're
doing the same thing over and over and
over again and getting the same results
someone said that's insanity
and they're they think not I have to do
something different they think I just
have to do this harder and that's a big
mistake you know we hear this invest in
ourselves and it sounds so cliche but so
many writers have invested probably time
in contests and who knows film festivals
whatever how many of them actually take
the time to invest as as cliche and sort
of whatever as it sounds in
themselves not not everybody and the
truth is that writers spend tons of
money on the course that's going to
teach them how to write the best the
next best
screenplay but they don't spend the
money on how they can improve their
chances not just a script people really
feel in this business like if I write a
great script it's the golden ticket it's
the Willy Wonka golden ticket I don't
have to do anything else there's tons of
other things you have to do and learning
what those are is worth investing in and
having support for what you want to do
is worth investing in absolutely because
where people get stuck is with their
work um with their attitude with their
Community not being big enough you have
to have a ever growing community of
mutually beneficial relationships it's
learning how to talk about themselves
where they also get stuck is they don't
have someone to to be accountable to
having that accountability is huge if
you want to make a change in your course
are you offering accountability Partners
or mentors good
question in the course we talk about
finding an accountability partner it
might be somebody from your life it
might be somebody in the class and what
that person's job is is to is for you to
say to them this is what I'm going to do
and this is when I'm going to do it and
they hold you to it um I talk about
something called bookending where if
there's something difficult you have to
do you have to make a phone call you
have to write a scene that's so
challenging you have to go to an event
that you don't want to go to you call
your or text or email your
accountability partner first you say I'm
gonna do this thing and then as soon as
you do it
you contact them again and say I did it
it's like checking a box it feels so
good do you also talk about building a
network I know networking is sort of a
funny word um community building a
community a community of mutually
beneficial relationships this business
is based on relationships everybody
knows that the more people you know the
more chances there are that you're going
to find out about an opportunity or an
opportunity will present themselves now
there's a lot of people that are stuck
because they don't want to go to events
they don't want to ask people for help
they're the opposite of somebody that
says hi read my script they're people
that have met people who' have said I'd
like to help you and they never follow
up following up is a big thing so many
of my clients say I met all these great
people and I just let it go cold how do
I get back to having a relationship with
them and I talk about that in the course
um the more people you know in a in an
authentic way the more opportunity is
going to come your
way